this has the makings of a very eventful
special day in baseball and specifically
perhaps for the blue jays sit back enjoy
it this is why we played 161
for this game right here to get to the
playoffs the blue jays must win today
and have either the red sox or yankees
lose in order to make it into some kind
of a tiebreaker situation beyond today
making his career high 31st start you
can count on ryu he's going to get to
the post and he's going to make his
starts this is a career high now 31st
start
taking on the orioles for the fifth time
and away we go at rogers center with a
first pitch swinging a ground ball right
at bo buschette one down number two
batter is ryan mount castle
like that two down that's a great sign
right there when he's got that thing
going down and away note the location
just off the plate i don't care about
the miles per hour just 81 miles per
hour the location
down and away from the power of mount
castle and it's owen 2.
got him great start for hyunjin ryu blue
jays with springer at the plate
yesterday hit his 20th home run with
toronto
fly ball left center
[Applause]
that's how you get this baby started
george springer with a lead-off home run
what a way to start the day for george
springer and the blue jays get off to a
fast start that's what they need and
george springer gives it to him
runners are on the corners one nothing
blue jays one down for t oscar hernandez
poke to right field a base hit
simeon will come in to score buchet
around to third rbi single hernandez it
is two to nothing
this is exactly what the doctor ordered
for toronto a two-nothing start rbi
114 for t oscar hernandez four of the
first five blue jays have come up with
hits already
lined up the middle caught by the
leaping shortstop martin and the runners
hold a line driving 103 miles an hour
off the bat stared by a leaping richie
martin at shortstop that's the second
out and it'll bring up santiago espinal
coming off another good game
line to left a base hit he's done it
again
the shed in to score hernandez stops at
second rbi single espinal and it is
three to nothing guerrero comes up with
a man on
major league leader and runs scored in
total bases he leads the american league
in on base percentage
ops and slugging percentage the pitch by
diplon swinging a drive out to deep
right field you can't forget it
not sure you can have a noisier 30 000
than the crowd right now for the rogers
center number 48 for vladi to make it
five to nothing
you just keep adding on and that was a
bullet to right field he has come back
to life at the right time for the blue
jays number 48 tying salvador perez for
the major league lead with that home run
vladimir guerrero jr has now hit more
home runs as a 22 year old than anyone
in major league history blue jays
leading 5-0 ryu goes to work on tyler
tyler
nevin
a big blast that one is way back
and gone
wow up into the third deck and welcome
to the big leagues tyler nevin
his first career home run a loud one wow
that was a large one i think that landed
in the third deck it almost got up there
where jose canseco hit one many many
moons to go way up in the fourth deck
your bases loaded two down springer got
it toronto loud early the 2-1 pitch that
is crushed deep left center field back
goes mullins at the wall and it is gone
it's gone
grand slam george springer he gets a
pitch over the plate
no situation is too big for him he's
hitting too many big games
and he comes through again for the blue
jays the ninth grand slam they've hit
this year and his sixth career grand
slam multi-home run game all ready for
springer and how about the tear that he
is on right now in recent games
he is 12 for his last 21 with all kinds
of power
and you can't wipe the smile off his
face right now
of space to work with as a big
left-hander rocks into the wind-up
and he gets a chase there from austin
hayes for his fifth strikeout
and again if there is to be baseball
tomorrow they'll want us as many rested
relievers as possible so the more they
can get out of ryu today the better
first and second one out nine to one in
the fourth inning where he won't need to
start it
every out's a big one though and there's
strikeout number six for ryu boy his
change up is so good it's close enough
to get those oriole hitters fishing for
it it comes to the plate you see it and
then it disappears underneath the bat
there's tyler nevin who hit his first
major league home run in his first
at-bat
curveball ground ball to third
espinal wins the race and the side is
retired no runs couple of singles two
men left and second and third nobody out
the orioles have to bring the infield in
again forte oscar hernandez
and that's a base hit
guerrero in to score the shed had to
avoid the ball and steel comes in to
score
and it is 11-1
both rows as that ball whistled right
through him vladimir guerrero jr scores
his 123rd
run of the season beau is right behind
him blue jays tack on two more here in
the fourth they have scored multiple
runs in each of their first four at bats
and gungeon ryu is back on the mound the
lakers coming up for the orioles ready
for the 1-2 ryu fires and he hit the
outside corner with strike three
strikeout number seven for hyunjin ryu
he's giving up a pair of one out singles
here in the fifth inning well the guy at
the plate he sure got better this year
brian montcastle
whether he's rookie of the year second
in the voting won't change the year he's
having
and hits that on the nose look at the
play from beshet gets one on to first
guerrero can't handle it it goes into
the seats and martin will score
the orioles have the bases loaded and
pedro severino is coming to the plate
the 0-2 pitch on a line out to right
field hernandez has got it
and the side is retired the orioles
leave them loaded now marcus simeone for
three had an infield hit back in the
first
3-2 simeon rockets it an absolute no
doubter going into the 200 level number
45 for marcus simeon that ball was
punished it's the fourth home run for
the blue jays this afternoon
his 45th of the year 12-2 toronto
merryweather needs something on the
ground to get out of this frame pitch to
severino semorino sends a fly ball to
straight away center the catch is made
by springer tagging in third here comes
hayes the springer throw is cut off
behind the mound by vladimir guerrero
junior
orioles score for the third time today
austin hayes been hit on the toe with a
pitch and he's also been hit in the ribs
with a pitch
line drive base hit for hayes rounding
third here comes mullins he will score
without a throw
hernandez gets it back to the middle of
the diamond on the rbi base hit for
austin eighth now the massimber is into
the game to work the ninth inning pat
valaka with the blue jays and out away
and a ground ball to third
and that will do it
the blue jays did what they had to do
this afternoon they pick up the win